hi everyone this video is inspired by
Stephen Hawking who I'm sure you would
have heard passed away recently and that
is sad especially as a physics student I
was heavily inspired by people including
Stephen Hawking I remember that his book
a brief history of time was I think the
first physics book I ever checked out
from my school library so I feel like
I've gone through my physics education
and looking up to him as one of the role
models and physics so it was really sad
to hear about him passing away but today
I thought I'd play some universe sandbox
do some black hole physics and maybe
look at some Hawking radiation so it's
been a while since I've played this game
and I feel like I have probably
forgotten how to play but that's alright
we'll see how we go
when I add a black hole I think a black
hole 100 times the mass of the Sun
sounds alright so let's just put that
out there
this will have a little bit of stars in
the background for this so you can
actually see the black hole so black
holes are pretty terrifying I think
that's one of the most interesting
things about them though and that's one
of the reasons why I like the work
someone like Stephen Hawking so much is
that he talks about these really
interesting and fundamental ideas about
physics let's see if we can add some
things in orbit around here get some
stars get the Sun okay how do I launch
this let's just put them
put a few songs out here somewhere okay
where are we okay they were launched
nothing is about Co let's do this from a
bird's-eye view that might be better and
let's give it a pause as well okay
here we got a few a bit closer in there
and play
[Music]
okay so we can see them being ripped
apart by the tidal forces of the black
hole I spoke about this in my last video
about yet gravitational tidal forces and
how they rip apart objects okay I wanted
to put some things in close to this
black hole so that we can start to get
out of a bit of an accretion disk
building up around it I don't think
we're close enough yet so let's go right
and close what it looks like we have a
supernova happening out there from some
sons that are colliding
it's ignore that
okay well at least you can see the black
hole found because the dust from the
supernova is lighting things up a little
a black hole has an event horizon and
that's sort of this blackest area around
the outside the sort of rim and at that
point pretty much light can't escape so
anything that goes past the event
horizon like the attraction pulling it
inwards is so strong that even light
can't escape you can't escape whoo once
you're at that point and so that's why
black holes are black and that's because
my can't escape but Hawking radiation is
about the idea that something is
actually emitted from a black hole and
that is something called Hawking
radiation and it's something that will
eventually
cause the black hole to lose mass and
dissipate away to nothing which is
interesting as opposed to the idea that
they just stay there forever so the
explanation I've heard is that at the
very rim of the black hole
you've got virtual particles so you've
got pairs of particles like particles
and antiparticles popping into existence
in pairs and usually they would
annihilate each other pretty much
instantly and disappear but if you've
got these particle and antiparticle
pairs originating at the very rim of the
black hole then one of the pair would be
essentially sucked into the black hole
leaving the other pair to have the other
one of the pair to have nothing to
annihilate with and to escape away
escape away from the black hole and
essentially that is the Hawking
radiation it's material particles that
are leaving the black hole the particle
that would get sucked into the black
hole would have a negative mass and so
that would give the effect of the black
hole itself losing mass so let's talk
about a few other things now take a look
at a few other setups here in universe
sandbox and talk about some of Stephen
Hawking's quotes and things that he said
that I thought were interesting so we've
got the solar system here let's zoom in
on earth
here we are oh that's nice let's slow it
down alright so this is more of a
real-time sort of thing one had second
per game second where we've gotta look
Australia's in the dark but we can go
over there so one quote that I wrote
down is something that I've heard
attributed to Stephen Hawking and that
was the phrase look up at the stars and
knock down at your feet this is
something I thought was interesting
because like this was something that I
used to say I used to think you know the
most magical thing you can ever think
about in space is to look up at the
stars and imagine sort of our place in
the universe and what's out there just
to see us in the grand scheme of things
I just I still can't really think of
anything more beautiful than that and
more important as a way to level
ourselves and to see yeah how we fit
into the scheme of things
but I don't necessarily think it is a
bad thing to also look down at your feet
I think that once you can gain a lot of
perspective from looking up that
perspective might almost be lost if
you're missing the things around you and
your day-to-day life if you're not
looking down at where humans have come
from in our origins and how we interact
with each other today and relating that
to the bigger goals you might have
looking up and the bigger dreams for
Humanity I think it would be ashamed to
ignore the importance of of what's heat
down here for us now there's a lot of
beauty in in life on earth and I think
it took me a little bit longer to
realize that and to actually yeah find
wonder and the everyday things and
beauty and everyday things instead of
only looking to space and astronomy to
find beauty so looking back at the
simulation that this is actually a
particularly cool setup here because for
the earth got the moon out here and then
if we keep zooming out that's the
trajectory of the earth oh was this
we have the Tesla Roadster seem right in
on that
and there we go as there's us and that's
should be kind of representative of
where the roadster is now I hope so you
know it's it's got pretty far but in
terms of celestial distances it's still
much much closer to Earth than it is to
Mars or or anything else at all so it's
it's gonna need to be keep driving for a
while but it'll get somewhere and
another quote from Stephen Hawking that
I thought was interesting was one where
he said the human race doesn't have a
future if it doesn't go into space and
you know what I I believe in that I
think humans need to go to space I think
it's just as important as I don't know
solving problems on earth in the really
long term that is to me there's a lot of
reasons why I believe we should go into
space like one of them is just that it's
that natural human desire to want to
explore around us like people many many
years ago wanted to explore the other
countries on the earth they weren't just
content to stay in the country they were
born in the country they knew they
wanted to see what else is on the earth
and we are now glad that they went out
and explored because we live in all
parts of the globe and I think it's sort
of that same feeling I feel like it
would be a massive shame
if all of humanity only ever existed on
the earth on this very tiny corner of
things so space travel also plays a huge
role in giving us unity and giving us a
perspective as you know needing to come
together as one planet and one nation
really to be able to go out and explore
space or the soul system or anywhere I
think we do need to recognize ourselves
as being united in a sense and I think
space travel is one of those things that
you know would hopefully unite people to
a common goal and I really look forward
to that I really look forward to seeing
people do more in space travel and to
seeing more people do it as a
collaboration for our next stop let's go
and look at some exoplanets all right so
we're off to Trappist one a red dwarf
star nearly 40 light-years from the
solar system it has three earth-sized
exoplanet discovered well that was
before they discovered for additional
exoplanets
so you know some of these planets here
could be quite like this and potentially
a second home for us if only we could
travel a few lightly light-years to get
here you know the fact that they are
like Earth means that even if we can't
get here possibly what does live on some
of these planets if there is any any
life out here you know could have
evolved similar to life on Earth there
could be some similar conditions if
these these planets are also and like a
similar Goldilocks zone of terms of
temperature the ability to have water
oxygen and atmosphere it's plausible
that things could have evolved out here
similar to life on Earth
and maybe that leads me to my next
philosophical quote from Stephen Hawking
he said that in his opinion there is no
aspect of reality beyond the reach of
the human mind
now that's an awesome quote and you know
I think it's true to some extent Stephen
Hawking kind of demonstrated that
through his life and his philosophy
where despite being
physically held back by an illness he
didn't let that hold back his mind and
he essentially traveled the universe
many times in his mind and unraveled
secrets about the universe about how
about holes work and all sorts of things
from the comfort of Earth we can imagine
our way to any place and do pretty much
anything with our imaginations one thing
I struggle to do with my imagination and
I think people struggle to do in general
is to actually imagine what life would
look like elsewhere in the universe
so I feel like humans may be forever
limited to imagining extraterrestrial
life that is similar to life we already
know life on Earth I feel like all the
depictions of aliens I've ever seen have
been based on you know odd-looking
humans or odd-looking animals I feel
like I've never really seen a depiction
that has actually thought outside the
box and I feel like maybe the human mind
is just configured to only ever imagine
life the way we know it
you know I I'd want to believe that
there could be life out there that
doesn't exist in a physical form at all
that is just essentially you know a
cloud computing Network existing that
covers some planet out there but I can't
really imagine or fathom that and you
know I I would love to see some more
depictions of alien life that isn't
based on earth life because I don't
think it should be I think that given
the fact that conditions would be so
different for life to develop and that
they might have had vastly different
timescales maybe so much more time than
us to develop to advance how could we
ever possibly assume that it's going to
be similar to life on Earth that's one
thing that I find you know hard to
imagine but I love trying to picture it
maybe out here in the Trappist system
you know some of that life exists and I
wonder what it does look like all right
I'm gonna read you one more quote but
I'm looking for a simulation that's
sufficiently philosophical
we're to 1 and the solar system that
seems cool it let's see what that's like
alright so this is going to be a
simulation of some of the nests a
Voyager probes
let's see where they're at okay
here's Voyager 2
[Music]
I've been zooming for a while it must be
small doesn't exist see a picture of it
oh that's dark
can I is there light in this game that
we can get a silhouette and now let's go
look for a light
[Music]
okay yeah we can see Voyager 2 out here
the last quote I was going to read was
one from Stephen Hawking so nothing is
quite beautiful he said that we are all
time travelers journeying together into
the future it is now up to us to make
that future a place we want to visit I
think that's nice
you know the Voyager spacecraft is
venturing out into the future it's going
to get further than we're going to get
considering none of us have left yet but
you know if we can go all the way back
to earth
you're even earthbound we are voyages as
well into the future and whether it's on
earth or just outwards into the solar
system we want to make the future
somewhere worth venturing into
so I hope that's a little bit of
motivation for your day thanks for
watching I don't know if you've noticed
but I I have been a little bit absent
from YouTube in the last few weeks I at
one point promised to make 2 videos a
week but I haven't quite been able to
manage that I think I've just been
really busy with PhD stuff a little bit
stressed I'm trying to make as many
videos as I can and I've got a few
exciting ones lined up to make in the
next week so we'll see how they go
[Music]